what what's driven this inflation is it
just down to the weaker pound or other
other things as well I think the yeah I
think it's a weaker pound that's driven
the inflation we at JD I was looking
this morning we were actually consistent
with last year in terms of the price in
our our average selling price has stayed
the same
slightly above maybe half a percent
that's all in terms of the average
selling price for footwear an average
selling price for textiles but that can
be because models change and you know
the it can it commit to do with the
technical content of the of the Footwear
in particular
so you're basically absorbing these
price rises rather than passing them on
to customers so a significant degrees is
down to our product mix it's not a
cannot a discrete consistent offering
from year to year and what about the
manufacturers themselves are they taking
some of the pain as well I think they're
taking some of the pain and as I say
it's a twist because that they're
largely dollar based so there has been
some pressure on it but they are taking
some of the pain as well so one of the
big things for you over the last few
years has been this athletic athleisure
put me teeth in and say a right trend I
mean the obits were being written for it
off do we have profits or warnings
recently from Foot Locker you seem to be
defying that today yeah I mean I think
that's been overhyped you know I think I
think there has been a cultural changing
in urban living and the the youth
culture and I think that there is a lot
more fitness around and so I actually
think that the the demise of athleisure
has been has been overhyped I just think
Foot Locker
quite rightly in their statement said
that there hasn't been as many innovate
innovative new Footwear models in the
half-year as there were the previous
half year but JD is at the forefront
there's a lot of diversity about it and
we've been able to absorb that as well a
lot of retailers are threating about the
threat of Amazon I mean you know they've
just bought whole food
so the grocer's are now in a bit of us
do one of the other things they've done
lately is said to Nike that they can
start selling directly on Amazon is that
a big threat to you that's mainly in the
US at the moment and it it really
operates at the sub premium level to a
greater degree so that we JD again we're
at the cutting edge so we're always
selling new models new new technologies
so the latest Footwear the latest
premium Footwear and that isn't affected
by omens and Plus Amazon isn't in Europe
where we we have our predominant retail
outlets all right Peter cow gear we're
gonna leave it there thanks very much
you join make it great to see you Cheers